[Музика]
[Музика
] Вато, який особливо знає, що
я мормон
Примадонна Nestle потребує портативного лазера для
вимірювання енергії
.  тварина до Мішель і оглянути
себе Амо Шива косабу Стів ігнорувати
принаймні зустрінеться в основному сплячим
[Музика]
привіт мене звати Ольга манма я
вчитель англійської
[музика
] добре привіт Бертрам привіт добре мене
звати Ольга і я буду  викладання
англійської мови це менше номер два і ми
сьогодні говоримо про мистецтво це
чудова тема дуже добре
я можу попросити вас подивитись на цей прекрасний
колаж добре що перше, на що ви
звертаєте увагу на розписи вуличного мистецтва
плакати цегла красиві стіни для
фарбування живопис  і декорації о ой,
це чудово, я перевірив ваш
словниковий запас, тому тепер я відчуваю себе більш
комфортно щодо того, чому я збираюся
навчити вас чудово для нашої аудиторії, я
хотів би представити вам гарне  o
це міністр закордонних справ правильно
я напишу іноземні справи для наших
студентів для аудиторії так
правильно мені дуже подобається слово іноземний чи можемо
ми придумати сполучення слів з
тим, що іноземний іноземний іноземний студент,
наприклад іноземні гості так
іноземна країна так іноземний  пригода
добре будь-яка іноземна мова іноземна
мова, звичайно, як я міг пропустити ту
одну хорошу іноземну валюту так, це
гроші, дуже дякую, тому у нас сьогодні є
міністр закордонних справ як наш
особливий гість, як я вже
згадував раніше  буду говорити
про дивне, який твій улюблений вид
мистецтва ні, я люблю малювати, але мені також подобається
сучасний дизайн і особливо цифровий
дизайн, я думаю, що це створює багато
можливостей для творчих людей, щоб
досліджувати кордони мистецтва як такого хорошого,
ми знаємо, що  все мистецтво поділяється
на кілька типів, які є візуальними
і прикладними, дивлячись на
зображення, чи можете ви вгадати, які будуть
основні типи o  f візуальне мистецтво добре
малюнок з правого боку мм-хм
добре живіт працює
добре красивий твір архітектури
нанесено прямо дуже добре
на вашому столі у вас уже є деякі інші
види мистецтва, які я хотів би, щоб ви
віднесли до них  три основні
студенти будуть сидіти на своїй дошці, і ви
маєте їх прямо перед вами,
будь ласка, згрупуйте їх у три різні
групи візуальне виконання та застосування, так що
живопис - це візуальна музика виконується
дизайн інтер'єру застосовується дизайн одягу
, хоча це приємно
подивіться також і на моду, щоб це
було певною мірою наочним
ремесла з дерева застосовуються архітектура
використовується малювання візуальний танець виступає
театр і фільм
добре це виконує, але, звичайно, це
також може бути до певної міри візуальним
спів виконання скульптура це
візуально добре і фотографія  є візуальним -
дуже добре дуже цікаво ви
хотіли б побачити прабатька Вікіпедії будь-який
інший веб-сайт пропонує звичайно дуже
добре давайте  о, ось як
вони готуються до рису, давайте перевіримо,
чи були ви праві щодо архітектури.
Архітектура пішла до прикладного мистецтва, так,
у Вікіпедії, а також на моєму столі дуже
добре, а як щодо кіно та театру, кіно
та театр сценічного мистецтва як у
Вікіпедії, так і  на моєму столі так, це
тому, що я читав Вікіпедію перед уроком,
добре, а як щодо художніх галерей, як
часто ви б ходили в художню галерею
добре, що раніше було моєю звичайною практикою
до коронавірусу, і ми всі знаємо, що
галереї були закриті так
тимчасово, але  як тільки пандемія
закінчиться, я маю намір отримати
свою практику відвідувати галереї
разом зі своїми дітьми,
дуже добре, добре, дуже дякую
дуже добре, молодці, молодці, я сподіваюся, що
все добре, дуже добре,
ми переходимо до наступного завдання  з вами
праворуч,
не могли б ви ідентифікувати зображення
з деякими словами справа від вас,
наприклад скульптура гравітація цифрове мистецтво,
але я хотів би, щоб ви використовували синонім
до самої фрази  я думаю, що мені та іншим
вчителям не подобається Я вважаю, що правильно, у мене
є запропонований список, який ви можете використовувати
замість Я думаю, чи не могли б ви прочитати список,
будь ласка, я вважаю, на мою думку,
на мою точку зору це здається, наскільки  Я
стурбований дуже добре, чи можу я зробити
приклад номер один, я вважаю, що малюнок А
– це картина, я вважаю, так що два дуже добре, чи
можу я попросити вас зробити решту, звичайно,
дякую, на мою думку, малюнок B – це графіті
, мені здається, малюнок C – це  фотографія
або насправді я не можу зрозуміти,
що таке зображення C, якщо у вас є
запропоновані шість слів, і якщо ми знаємо, що
D, ймовірно, в порядку, я б сказав, що
зображення C є цифровим цифровим мистецтвом,
дякую, так, мені здається, що це зображення  D — це
чудова фотографія з моєї точки
зору, зображення E — архітектура, що
стосується мене, зображення F — скульптура,
відмінно добре зроблено,
що було п'ять синонімів, чи я
думаю, що я вірю в свою думку, наскільки
мене це стосується,
відмінно в моєму  точка зору так, і я
б додав, я думаю, риг  ht є, але
все, що ви хотіли б додати, ну
насправді,
я думаю, що ще можливо,
мені здається так, чудово, молодці, будь ласка,
використовуйте різноманітні слова, щоб
висловити свою думку, я думаю, це дуже
нудно, ви згодні, що я думаю, що дуже
нудно абсолютно дуже добре ми
готові рухатися далі, щоб розширити наш словниковий запас і
мистецтво дуже добре Метро у вас буде
листок з тим же завданням, що й у
мене на дошці, і завдання LU,
звичайно, читати список слів
запропоновано ліворуч і щоб узгодити його
з описом добре, я дам
вам хвилину на це добре так дуже
добре,
тому ваш час починається зараз
[Музика]
право, я думаю, ви готові я дуже
добре, мені здається  вам здається дуже
добре давайте перевіримо ваші ідеї та порівняємо
це з моїми уявленнями дуже добре художник
- це людина, яка дуже добре малює картини
і як би ви назвали грубий і
швидко зроблений малюнок ескіз дуже добре
що щодо шедевра щось
зроблено було  велика майстерність добре, який
твір мистецтва ви можете назвати шедевром, на
вашу власну думку, ну, їх багато,
це залежить від того, що ми маємо на увазі. Мені
подобаються картини епохи
Відродження художників епохи Відродження Я думаю, що більшість з
них є шедеврами відмінно дуже
добре як би  ви описуєте майстерню
це добре освітлена робоча кімната художника
чи скульптора дуже добре а
палітра це тонка дошка, на якій
живописець лежить і змішує кольори дуже добре
як би ми назвали людину, яка позує для
художників і скульптур, amodal
дуже добре, і я думаю, що ми не розповіли
про пензель, пензлик це щось, що
треба малювати дуже добре, добре зроблено мій
студент молодець дуже добре, ми
готові рухатися далі, і ще трохи
про мистецтво дуже добре, чи можу я  попросіть вас
прочитати список слів пейзаж
натюрморт портрет морський пейзаж
батальон дуже добре що щодо Мерилін
Монро це портрет
це портрет яке прекрасне
море
це морський пейзаж морський пейзаж чи знаєте ви  n
це чи це те, що ви
насправді морський пейзаж, це не те слово, яке
ви зазвичай зустрічаєте, але тому я б
заохочував запам'ятати його та
продемонструвати знання дуже добре, чи хочете ви, щоб
я зафіксував це в нашому словнику, вибух,
безперечно, дуже хороший морський пейзаж
дуже добре, а як щодо чорно-білої
картини, ну, це здається битвою,
бойовою фігурою, дуже добре, а як
щодо картини Фішера, це
натюрморт, це несвіже життя, дуже добре, і один
посередині пейзаж пейзаж
давайте  перевірте, наскільки добре ви запам'ятали всі
ці слова гарно виконано Battlekey
пейзаж морський пейзаж добре зобразити
натюрморт дуже добре ви не використовували жодної допомоги
так дуже добре Мені подобається Сподіваюся, кожен може
повернутися до цього і пам'ятати, що
описав свою улюблену картинку, ви можете
назвати її так  дуже важливо молодець,
зараз подивіться на це фото,
як ви думаєте, хто ця людина
, я б здогадався, що це відомий британський
художник, ім'я якого мені невідоме, добре,
чи не так  чорнила ця жінка може бути
моєю подругою, вона точно буде
твоєю подругою добре, а
як щодо того, щоб припустити, що ця жінка
незнайомка, я щойно знайшов її фотографію в
Інтернеті, це цілком можливо -
дуже добре, ви повинні вибрати одну добре, я
йду  для відомого британського художника, о, о,
це моя найкраща подруга, вона британка, і
її звуть Світанок, як тільки я сказав їй,
що буду викладати англійську мову
11 рік і буду висвітлювати тему
мистецтва, вона сказала, що у мене є  чудові новини для
вас, у нас є друг і Кумін, у якої
скоро день народження, насправді вона
надіслала мені голосове повідомлення, тому що я
не міг спілкуватися, коли вона зі мною зв'язалася,
ми збираємося прослухати голосове повідомлення Дон,
і вам доведеться відповісти
деякі запитання добре добре, давайте подивимося
на запитання, на які вам доведеться
відповісти. Це завжди гарна ідея, щоб
уважно прочитати запитання, які вам
надають, перш ніж виконувати аудіювання,
будь ласка, якщо вам потрібно
і вас просять робити завжди  зроби це
ри  Так що це п'ять питань, на які
ви не маєте відповіді на питання
номер п'ять, тепер ви побачите це на
наступному слайді
після дуже гарного прослуховування, але я б
дуже хотів, щоб ви прочитали запитання, чи
можете ви зробити це зараз, будь ласка, переконайтеся, що
купили  картина невідомого художника,
художника чи відомого художника, скільки
мій друг заплатив за картину 100
британських фунтів вісімнадцять британських фунтів
дуже добре, у неї дуже гарне ім'я,
чи не так ви вважаєте, що це абсолютно
світанок, світанок, так, так,
пам'ятайте відомий фільм від заходу до світанку,
так, дуже добре, дуже добре,
Роуен, правда, ми готові слухати, так,
добре,
добре, ми послухаємо мій  повідомлення друзів
двічі ви пам’ятаєте, що були
запитання ах, добрішими, ми
повернемося до них, ви побачите їх
пізніше, чи готові ви слухати
так, давайте почнемо привіт, о, вибачте, що сумую за тобою  u
Сподіваюся, ти здоровий, я просто хотів поговорити
з тобою про подарунок Сари на день народження. Я
бачив її за чашкою чаю минулого тижня, коли
ми ходили по магазинах у місті, і
вона згадала, що хотіла б нову фотографію для
своєї спальні. Я думав, що  був би
ідеальним подарунком на її день народження від
вас і мене. Сьогодні я був у Лондоні, шопінг на
Оксфорд-стріт, і я пішов до художньої
галереї, щоб подивитися на їхні фотографії, у них
було багато справді гарних малюнків
в рамках за дуже розумними цінами, які я
намагався знайти  картина, яка б відповідала її
квартирі, яка дуже сучасна і модна, її
спальня пофарбована в блідо-зелений сіро
-блакитний колір я побачив справді чудову абстрактну
картину, я думаю, що їй дуже сподобається,
тому я купив її для неї, я думаю, що вона підійде до
її спальні  ідеально, оскільки вона має
ті самі кольори, що й її килими та
штори, також вона буде відповідати іншій
картині, яку вона має в її квартирі,
картина була зроблена відомим художником
Бенедиктом Девісом, і я знаю, що їй дуже
подобаються його картини, оскільки вони дуже
популярні  Спочатку його малюнок коштував
фунти, але в магазині був розпродаж разом
із знижкою 20% на все, тому
ціна була в нашому бюджеті, ви можете заплатити мені,
коли я побачу вас на її вечірці наступного тижня,
жінка в магазині була дуже корисною,
і у неї було красиво  запакувала
картину в подарунок, щоб ми могли подарувати її
ввечері наступної суботи, якщо ви пам’ятаєте, будь ласка, чи
можете ви купити листівку на день народження, щоб ми
обидві підписали, і ми можемо подарувати її їй у
ресторані, я дуже чекаю
зустрічі з вами  День народження Сари наступного тижня подбає про святкування дня народження Сари,
і я поговорю з вами
незабаром, коли ви почуєте ресторан, який
вам сподобався, чому ви полюбили добре, тому що
я не пам’ятав останнього запитання, тому
я подумав, що, можливо, останнє питання
стосується ресторану, коли
я подумав, що ви сміялися, тому що ви знаєте
, що зараз ресторани не відкриті, це буквально
незаконно дуже добре останнє питання
номер 5, яке студенти побачать
на екрані, було коли насправді
вечірка мала бути дуже гарною, ми
йдемо  я послухаю його ще раз
правильно, і щоб кожен дійсно міг робити
нотатки та правильно відповідати на всі запитання,
привіт, Ольго, вибачте, що сумую за вами
Сподіваюся, ви добре, я просто хотів поговорити
з вами про подарунок Сари на день народження.
чашка чаю минулого тижня, коли
ми ходили по магазинах у місті, і
вона згадала, що хотіла б нову фотографію для
своєї спальні, я думав, що це буде
ідеальний подарунок на її день народження від
вас і мене. Сьогодні я був у лондонських магазинах на
Оксфорд-стріт, і я  пішла до художньої
галереї, щоб подивитися на їхні фотографії, у них
було багато справді гарних малюнків
в рамках за дуже розумними цінами. Я
намагався знайти картину, яка б відповідала її
квартирі, яка дуже сучасна та модна, її
спальня пофарбована в блідо-зелений сірий
та блакитний колір  Я побачив справді чудову абстрактну
картину, я думаю, що вона їй дуже сподобається,
тому я купив її для неї, я думаю, що вона
ідеально підійде до її спальні, оскільки вона має
ті ж кольори, що й її килим і
штори, а також вона буде відповідати іншій її
картині  у її квартирі
картину зробив відомий художник
Бенедикт Девіс, і я знаю, що їй дуже
подобаються його картини, оскільки вони дуже
популярні, спочатку картина коштувала
сто фунтів, але в магазині був розпродаж
зі знижкою 20% на все,
тому ціна була  у нашому бюджеті ви можете
заплатити мені, коли я побачу вас на її вечірці наступного
тижня, жінка в магазині була дуже
корисною, і вона красиво
запакувала картину в подарунок, щоб ми могли
подарувати її ввечері наступної суботи, якщо ви
пам’ятаєте, будь ласка, чи можете ви купити  листівку на день народження,
щоб ми обидві підписали, і ми можемо подарувати
її їй у ресторані Я дуже
чекаю побачити вас на святі
дня народження Сари наступного тижня, подбайте, і
я скоро поговорю з вами
дуже добре, давайте розглянемо питання
і відповісти на них прямо, щоб ми тепер дізналися,
що це твоя подруга, і її звуть
світанок, світанок дуже добре, і ми йдемо на
чиюсь вечірку Сарріс, жаль, так, наші
друзі, дуже добре, давайте подивимося на
питання дуже добре, тому не втомлюйте
картину  від родини  наш художник дуже добре,
ти пам'ятаєш його ім'я
ах дебет ні щось подібне так
добре так, вона заплатила вісімнадцять британських
фунтів як ти, насправді вона купила, я
думаю, що вона заплатила вісімсот за це ні,
добре, початкова ціна була 1000 ієн,
а потім вона, але  магазин пропонував
розпродаж на 20%, тому вона заплатила
800 британських фунтів дуже ціну
без ваших обмежень добре бюджет
так, в межах бюджету дуже добре, а як
щодо кольорів, кольори
картини бліді, і вони відповідають тим
картинам, які вже є в
Квартира Сарріс і кольори її кімнати
також так, це дуже добре, а що
щодо вечірки, це наступного тижня, і це
субота, дуже добре, все добре на
вихідних, а потім ми можемо додати у
вихідні дуже гарне слово про додаткове запитання,
бонусне запитання саме для вас  була
щось, про що моя подруга згадала, що
вона хотіла б, щоб я купив що це
було листівка з днем народження дуже хо
оші британці такі традиційні на
іть зараз  у 21 столітті вони все ще
цінують рукописні
листівки з днем народження, підписані від руки. Ви робите це у св
їй родині з друзями, щоб об
інюватися листівками на день народження нічого добре, ми
е такі традиційні, як британці, ду
же добре, британці ду
е традиційні дуже добре давайте  перевірте,
чи були ви праві так
дуже добре як щодо вашої квартири дерево
деревина бліді кольори в ній переважають яскраві кольори
ми маємо картини яскравих кольорів у
нашій квартирі добре і хто
вибирає шанси, які у вас є у вашому
будинку добре ми  не вибираючи це
свідомо, це просто життя, яке, ви
знаєте, надає нам різні
картини, а потім ми вибираємо, який з них
поставити на стіни нашої квартири
чудово, ми повернемося до цього дуже
добре, а тепер ви скажете три
картинки, а ви  доведеться вгадати
картинку, яку нарешті купили для
Сари, дуже добре, хм, я б
вибрав той, що посередині, добре чому,
тому що це єдиний, у якого є лише
блідий співрозмовник  lors у ньому праворуч від
малюнка праворуч має червоний колір, який є
яскравим, а зображення зліва
дійсно яскравим, справді яскравим, якби
ви вибирали картину для своєї
квартири в одній зі своїх кімнат, яку
б ви вибрали я  той, що
праворуч або той, що ліворуч, точно
не той, що посередині,
дуже добре, що приваблює вас на цих
фотографіях, баланс кольорів і більше,
я б сказав, хаотична структура
самої картини дуже добре, який стиль
можна сказати, що це  це явно
сучасне так сучасне мистецтво дуже
добре ви любите сучасне мистецтво
так дуже добре і який був останній
твір мистецтва, який ви добре купили,
як я сказав, ми зазвичай отримуємо мистецтво в
подарунок
твори мистецтва як подарунки, тому зараз
у нас в квартирі є картини сучасного мистецтва
і всі їх нам
подарували самі художники відмінно
що останній
увійшов у вашу родину
останній український конт  тимчасовий художник
Алексіс Я, він володіє особливою технікою,
він створює мистецтво в Інтернеті, тому це в
основному цифрове мистецтво, так, а потім він друкує
його на поверхні, так що це виглядає так, ніби
насправді це алюміній, це тверда
поверхня, але це виглядає як справжня
картина, тому це дуже  дуже особливий, і
він має свій власний стиль і власну
техніку, з якою він працює дуже добре,
що є традиційним типом того, що
ми зазвичай бачимо на картинах, ви бачите
різні фігури, традиційні фігури, як
ви правильно поставили на стіну
традиційні картини  зроблено на полотні
так, але тепер сучасне мистецтво дуже добре досліджує
інші поверхні, які можна використовувати для мистецтва,
тому полотно є, мабуть,
найдавнішим і
найтрадиційнішим.  все може бути серфінгіст
може серфінгувати як поверхня для мистецтва так дуже
добре дякую дуже правильно ми говорили
з вами про різні типи
фотографій пейзажі морська вода  pe
бойова фігура бойова фігура вони
гарні сталь мистецтво твоє життя так, ти любиш
мистецтво дуже добре, якщо ти дивишся на мене, тому що
ми іноді кажемо, що ти можеш побачити,
що подобається людині, який стиль, який подобається людині
, має у своїй чи  її квартира, як
ти думаєш, мій улюблений твір мистецтва
в моїй квартирі натюрморт звідки ти
знаєш, що це лише здогадка,
я не великий шанувальник натюрморту, однак у
мене є чудове зображення, яке є цифровим
мистецтвом, змішаним з фотографією  і все це
надруковано на шматку дерева, я зараз
шкодую, що не включив це в свою
презентацію, тому що вони дійсно
дуже м'які, ви повинні мати пару
картинок на стіні і змусити своїх
учнів здогадатися, яка з них вам найбільше
подобається.  дякую,
я створюю ще кілька уроків, які
я обов'язково включаю в те
дуже добре, що ви мені розповіли про
картини, але ми не обговорювали будь-які
інші види мистецтва, які у вас є у вашому
житловому просторі, що це добре, оскільки це добре
життєвий простір ти йо  Ви в основному зосереджуєтесь на
живописі, але у нас також є кілька
красивих скотчів, як покласти
тарілки
ручної роботи тарілки, одна з них
зроблена кримськотатарським художником, який
відновив стару техніку кримськотатарських
орнаментів чи можна сказати, що це кераміка
, це  кераміка у вигляді тарілки
дуже добре я б поставила слово портрет
для всіх наших учнів поезія так дуже
гарна
кераміка і що зазвичай глиняні вироби
з глини так це з глини я
поставлю це для всіх для всіх
учнів дуже добре  правильно,
і це на вашому столі, це на
стіні, це на столі, це на столі, це
дуже добре, я щасливий, чи є якісь скульптури ні не
дуже добре, а як щодо ваших дітей, чи
вони креативні, чи вони виробляють
щось, що у вас виставлено у
вашій квартирі так  у нас є картини,
намальовані нашою донькою, якій вісім
років у своїй квартирі, вона намалювала ті, що
малювала, коли їй було, можливо, шість чи навіть
п'ять, тому це досить наївне мистецтво, якщо я можу
сказати це так, але
ми думаємо, що я  Це добре, щоб вона пам’ятала
свої власні шедеври,
тому ми оформили це в рамку та повісили на стіну
в її власному дуже добре Мені дуже подобається
фраза, щоб бути в рамці, щоб бути дуже добре оформленою,
і як ви вибираєте, які
твори мистецтва створюють ваші діти  бути в
рамці чи не бути в рамці, це сімейне
рішення, добре, добре, щоб бути в
рамці, добре, я скажу це красиво, щоб бути
оформленим дуже добре, що ваш особистий
вибір, коли ви обираєте
твір мистецтва для свого друга  вам
подобається, щоб картину поставили в рамку. О, ви
дозволяєте власнику вирішувати, вставити її в
рамку чи залишити її без рамки. Я дозволю
власнику вирішувати, тому що спочатку багато
друзів багато моїх друзів вважають за краще
залишати картини без рамки і вважають, що
вони вирішують поставити її в рамку  тоді у них
обов’язково повинен бути вибір і вони самі вибирають
саму рамку, тому що
є багато варіантів,
і ви не можете точно вгадати, який смак
має ваш друг, дуже дякую
Метро Сподіваюся, вам сподобалося сьогодні менше
надзвичайно дуже добре, я сподіваюся, що ви
повернетеся додому, зараз дивлячись на
мистецтво навколо вас
ви можете створювати
себе із задоволенням, і більше того, я
настійно рекомендую стежити за вашими
уроками і дивитися кожен новий епізод,
дуже дякую, дуже дякую
Metro і дякую всім за
перегляд, поверніться до наступного уроку,
будь ласка,
[Музика]
Chidori chica, якби їх було два  запланований
час тесту на рок-параграф
Акіла Ваня добре, які значення мають
бути шахрайським каппа Стелла була
фортецею Patania на увазі за вето,
ми отримуємо найефективніші Я впевнений, що дізнався,
що Porsche міг побачити з
музикою VJ див. eSports Club III  вітаємо
з Cosmo на Хеллоуїн, ймовірно,
стане свідком того, як крихітні зловмисники розмовляють
з Чилі, відкривають мобільне
блюдо ранчо з блакитним сиром з акцентом бас-басу річки Типпекано.
він kimchi 9gt
chewy узбережжя помітно підводний режим
обов'язкова версія ми виграли ярди
супер жарко ой огайо зокрема в як
емблема або низамс д хвилина підтримка
Олеся занадто багато енергії для себе
основний аа шкода вечірка футбол далеко в
той час вклала йогу подіум вона  їздив на
ньому подивіться, а ваша фізична форма більше знає,
щоб Michelle knows em
nemours Urvashi vacasa підвищити, якщо ігнорувати, хто
дійсно буде говорити багато Lewis tea
[Музика]
ви